look at these tunnels that Hamas uses to
get its missiles Hamas is this
anti-israeli militant group down in the
Gaza Strip it's a part of Palestine Gaza
is sandwiched between Egypt the ocean
and hamas's enemy Israel they're totally
isolated and blockaded from the world
and yet they still manag to get all of
these rockets that they shoot into
Israel these rockets in their parts
mostly come from other countries like
Iran and Syria historically they've made
their way into the country through this
network of tunnels Israel is always
finding these tunnels and trying to shut
them down but they certainly still exist
they also do this thing where a ship
offshore will drop a floating capsule
full of weapons and it will be picked up
by these scuba Fighters One Way or
Another they use these black market
smuggling techniques to get these
Rockets into the country and they build
up a huge Arsenal and then they kind of
release them all at once which is what
they recently did starting this new war
if you want to understand what's
happening in this conflict follow along
for more I'm going to be covering this